[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde
l'Europe risque-t-elle la panne
d'énergie après deux années de covid et
la guerre en Ukraine déclenchée comme
nous le savons par la Russie en février
2022 l'Europe a révélé ses failles de
véritables béances dans le domaine de
l'énergie de toutes les énergies des
hydrocarbures au nucléaires et aux
énergies renouvelables pour comprendre
ce désordre énergétique européen d'abord
quelques chiffres avant le 24 février
2022 date de l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine l'Union européenne dépendait
dans son mix énergétique de près de 60%
des hydrocarbures source d'énergie quasi
absente d'Europe et pour 12% du charbon
une grande partie de ces énergies
importées de Russie près de 50% importés
de Russie en ce qui concerne le gaz et
le charbon depuis que l'embargo a été
décrété vis-à-vis de la Russie il ne
reste plus que 9% du gaz importé si l'on
reporte ce bouquet énergétique
c'est-à-dire cet ensemble des énergies à
la seule électricité qui représente le
quart de l'énergie primaire on observe
que le nucléaire monte à 25%, le gaz et
le charbon à 33% et les énergies
renouvelables pour 35%. pardon de ces
chiffres mais ils sont importants pour
comprendre la politique énergétique de
l'Europe on comprend bien sûr le choc
constitué par l'embargo russe et les
difficultés d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement dont la brutalité a
été marquée par un chiffre
l'augmentation du coût de l'électricité
multiplié par 4 à partir du coût du gaz
multiplié par 3 nous allons vous en
parler bien que ce chiffre soit en
baisse aujourd'hui il y a de surcroît
des causes endogènes à l'Europe dont les
moindres ne sont pas la décision brutale
de l'Allemagne en 2011 à l'époque avec
la chancelière Angela Merkel de sortir
du nucléaire la fermeture presque
partout exceptée en Europe de l'Est des
centrales à charbon la politique
française
erratique concernant sa filière
nucléaire un marché européen de
l'électricité complètement obsolète avec
des prix sous-évalués une insuffisante
production d'énergie renouvelable en
même temps que la production de base
c'est à dire celle qui est disponible à
tout moment se révéler défaillante bref
l'Union européenne a failli dans ce
domaine capital de l'économie mondiale
et qui demeure sous influence politique
pour en parler je vous présente mes
invités Christine
des millions vous êtes présidente de
l'uefe c'est-à-dire l'Union Française de
l'électricité Armand lafférrer vous êtes
directeur des affaires publiques chez
Orano
Erquy Maillard vous êtes directeur des
affaires européennes pour EDF Jacques
Percebois vous êtes professeur émérite
des Universités et économisent de
l'énergie et nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir pierre shelkens en audio
conférence et non visioconférence parce
que nous avons un petit problème
technique de transfert d'image je
rappelle monsieur shelken ce que vous
êtes directeur de l'énergie policy au
sein de la Commission européenne
[Musique]
première question qui vient à l'esprit
l'Europe de l'énergie est-ce que ça
n'est pas un leurre au regard de
l'expression des égoïsmes nationaux
notamment dans le domaine des mix
énergétiques et des sources variées
d'approvisionnement Christine Goubet mio
il faut revenir au départ au fait que la
l'unité européenne la Communauté
Européenne s'est construite sur
l'énergie revenant à la CK en fait la
Séka c'est bien la communauté du charbon
et de l'acier et c'est bien une des
toutes premières politiques que l'Union
européenne a constitué dans l'Europe
assis puis à 27 donc je crois que ça
c'est un point important après l'énergie
c'est un sujet éminemment politique et
les pays ont souhaité garder un principe
de subsidiarité et la souveraineté sur
leur mix énergétique et en effet c'est
un petit peu ça la dualité ou la
complexité que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est
une souveraineté sur son mix énergétique
avec des choix des pays qui sont
différents mais en même temps une
communauté d'intérêts sur l'énergie pour
le marché européen dans la compétition
internationale mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'on doit penser de cette dualité
la verrière égoïse nationaux d'un côté
politique européenne de l'énergie de
l'autre c'est ce que ça existe oui il
faut bien que ça existe pour une raison
simple c'est que l'Europe est un plateau
énergétique avec des intertonections
avec des échanges donc c'est bien à
marcher de l'énergie ensuite c'est dans
les traités européens et chaque État
doit
librement décidé de son mix électrique
ça n'empêche pas qu'il faut se
coordonner pour parler justement des
interconnexions pour parler des intérêts
communs pour parler des ça n'a peut-être
pas été fait suffisamment dans le passé
ou plus exactement ça a été fait dans le
passé mais avec une hypothèse qui est
une hypothèse qui s'est avéré fausse qui
est que on pourrait toujours se tourner
vers la Russie pour pour fournir du gaz
maintenant qu'on sait que ça n'est pas
le cas il faut que la coordination
reparte sur des bases plus réalistes ce
qui n'empêchera pas chaque pays de
décider librement de son mix alors qui
Maillard vous êtes à Bruxelles comme
directeur de DF pour les affaires
européennes vous avez le sentiment que
il y a une politique énergétique
européenne ou que vous défendez
c'est votre rôle d'ailleurs la politique
française mais comment ça s'exprime
cette dualité il y a très clairement des
orientations européennes en matière
énergie et dans le domaine climatique en
particulier en fait traditionnellement
quand on regarde les questions
énergétiques on doit résoudre 3 3
questions qui sont difficiles à
réconcilier la sécurité énergétique
le côté propre la décarbonation de cette
énergie et puis le coût de cette énergie
et souvent quand vous fait vous traitez
un problème vous oubliez une autre
partie de ce triangle ce qu'a fait assez
bien l'Union européenne c'est regarder
la décarbonation à la fois avec les
objectifs et là il y a une assez bonne
unité européenne quelque soit les
divergences en matière de décarbonation
l'Union européenne veut être le premier
continent neutre en carbone en 2050 et
puis sur la partie sécurité énergétique
en revanche comme l'a dit Armand
Laferrière tout à l'heure on s'est
reposé sur des hypothèses dangereuses
alors non seulement sur l'hypothèse de
Russie mais de la Russie mais en réalité
ce qu'a révélé la crise que vous
mentionnez au début c'est la crise de
toutes les énergies fossiles importées
parce que vous l'avez dit dans les
chiffres c'est très c'est très parlant
l'Union européenne au-delà l'électricité
pour son énergie au sens large dépend
encore beaucoup et beaucoup trop des
énergies fossiles et des énergies
fossiles importées donc maintenant si on
regarde l'avenir ce dont l'Europe a
besoin c'est de développer ses propres
sources d'énergie notamment
d'électricité qui soit à la fois
décarbonée on va rentrer disponible et
pas trop cher alors monsieur sherikens
vous vous êtes
j'allais dire docteur Europe qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui parce que je vous cacherai
pas que dans les différents pays
européens on critique beaucoup ce qui
est supposé être une politique
énergétique européenne donc à votre à
votre avis elle existe ou ce sont les
égoïsmes nationaux qui se disputent dans
ce domaine
je vais pas vous étonner en vous disant
que je partage pas tout à fait le
constat de départ d'introduction de
l'émission mais bon et ceci pour deux
raisons principales et bien parce que je
crois que l'Union européenne et les
états d'ailleurs et non seulement les
structures éthiques mais aussi des
entreprises et la société au sens large
est en train de faire face à choc à choc
très important et vous l'aviez vous-même
énoncé le fait de passer en quelques
mois à une importation de gaz russe qui
représentait et donc 40-45%
de la plantation totale à aujourd'hui 7%
plus ou moins et c'est un choc pour le
système de l'énergie évidemment mais
c'est surtout de retrouvons surtout dans
une situation aujourd'hui en bientôt en
décembre 2022 avec des stocks qui sont
bien avant et qui sont bien remplis avec
une
la certification des importations alors
tout n'est certainement pas parfait les
prix restent volatils ils restent à un
niveau élevé même si comme vous disiez
ils sont ils ont plutôt tendance à
chuter ces derniers temps mais simple
fait que nous pouvons rentrer dans la
dans l'hiver 2021 2020 2021 2023 pardon
de façon relativement sereine en termes
de sécurité d'approvisionnement pour
2023 2024
et là c'est justement maintenant nos
mesures exactement
s'oriente surtout et avant tout sur les
20 prochains en effet 2023 2024 et vous
avez vu ce qu'on a fait la dégustation
sur par exemple la plateforme d'achat
d'achat conjointe et justement très
orienté pour les 20 prochains merci
alors Jacques perce bois tout le monde a
souligné il y a une augmentation des
prix est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer
justement cette chose là
quoi il y a une indexation du coût du
kilowatt-heure d'électricité sur le gaz
et d'où cette effet si vous voulez de
multiplication des coûts de
l'électricité à partir des coûts du gaz
sans rentrer dans des détails techniques
mais pour les téléspectateurs alors je
crois que les pays de l'Union européenne
ont en commun la confiance dans les
mécanismes du marché par conséquent dans
le domaine de l'électricité on a mis un
marché un marché interconnecté entre les
différents pays européens et sur le
marché le prix d'équilibre se fait en
fonction du coût des différentes
centrales qui sont appelées c'est-à-dire
qu'on appelle les centrales électriques
en fonction des coûts qui sont
croissants des coupes marginaux
croissants c'est-à-dire des coups de
fonctionnement croissants et la dernière
centrale qui est appelée en ce moment
c'est une centrale à gaz
traditionnellement les centrales
thermiques comme les centrales à gaz
mais c'est vrai aussi pour le charbon
sont des centrales pour lesquels le coût
du combustible est un élément
constitutif important et donc le prix du
gaz s'est envolé et par ricochet le prix
de l'électricité s'est envolé puisque il
est aligné sur le coup de fonctionnement
de la dernière centrale qui est une
centrale à gaz donc c'est pas une
indexation on n'a pas volontairement
indexé le prix de l'électricité sur le
prix du gaz c'est la le fonctionnement
du marché qui fait ça alors le problème
c'est que ce marché si vous voyez c'est
comme un système d'enchères et tout le
monde est payé au même niveau
c'est-à-dire aux prélimites c'est-à-dire
au prix d'équilibre le prix que reçoit
la dernière centrale donc vous avez des
centrales qui reçoivent des rentes
relativement importantes très simplement
la France souhaiterait qu'on sorte de
cette relation mécanique l'Allemagne ne
veut pas pourquoi la France peut-elle
sortir et pourquoi l'Allemagne refuse
c'est pas vraiment que la France veut
sortir je pense que c'est simplement que
la France propose une mesure qui est
très qui est très proche de la mesure
pour poser par l'Espagne le constat est
le suivant puisque la faute revient à un
prix du gaz qui est élevé subventionnant
le gaz qui est utilisé pour la
production d'électricité mécaniquement
le prix de l'électricité chutras c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a vu en Espagne ceci
étant ça pose un centre de difficultés
les Allemands ne veulent pas cette
solution d'abord parce que ça leur
coûterait beaucoup plus cher parce
qu'ils suivent ils auraient beaucoup
plus de gaz à subventionner ensuite
parce qu'une partie de l'électricité
thermique il fabrique avec le gaz est
exporté vers la France aujourd'hui aux
heures de pointe et par conséquent il
propose d'autres mesures mais la France
ne veut pas sortir du marché dans l'état
qui a des choses elle veut simplement
proposer un certain nombre de correctifs
simplement ce qu'on constate que tous
les pays ne sont pas sur le même
longueur donc il y a d'autres solutions
d'ailleurs que celle-là mesure qui
Maillard oui je pense qu'il faut bien
distinguer le court terme du long terme
à court terme comme l'a dit professeur
perce-bois il y a effectivement un débat
pour savoir s'il faut mettre un plafond
au prix du gaz qu'on utilise pour faire
de l'électricité parce que c'est la
seule façon efficace de lutter contre
l'inflation des prix à court terme et
puis à long terme il y a un problème qui
est posé par les marchés c'est comment
est-ce que vous rémunérer les
investissements que vous avez fait pour
une entreprise comme EDF l'objectif ça
n'est pas de tondre les clients quand
les prix sont élevés c'est de rémunérer
ces investissements avec des prix qui
sont proches du coût moyen à long terme
de l'investissement et le problème qu'on
a c'est que le système qui est efficace
pour assurer au jour le jour à court
terme la sécurité c'est-à-dire que pour
que l'offre d'électricité la production
d'électricité rencontre la demande
d'électricité elle ne donne pas le bon
signal de prix pour couvrir le coût des
investissements et ça pardon juste pour
terminer et c'est un problème quand vous
avez la France qui investit dans des
moyens décarbonés et c'est là où
effectivement politiquement on comprend
qu'il peut y avoir une difficulté
pourquoi est-ce que
le consommateur français le contribuable
français accepterait un système où le
prix de l'électricité est et
couplé effectivement il est pas indexé
il est couplé au gaz alors que on
investit dans des sources des carbonées
mais ce sont deux sujets différents il y
a le court terme et le long terme
Monsieur Charles Kent sans polémiquer si
vous voulez avec la direction générale
de l'énergie et la Commission européenne
il se dit en France que dans ce domaine
là le bien sûr j'ai exagéré le différent
franco-allemand mais il se dit que
l'influence allemande prédomine et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on bouge pas de
ce mécanisme qui relie gaz et
électricité qu'est-ce que vous répondez
monsieur shelkens
mais comme l'a dit le marché électrique
européen et
à beaucoup de points à beaucoup de
points forts il nous a il nous a assuré
pendant de nombreuses années un système
en équilibre et qui nous fournissait une
sécurité d'approvisionnement aussi ce
marché européen il faut pas l'oublier
est extrêmement important en période de
crise pour justement équilibrer l'offre
et la demande au niveau 100 ce marché
européen nous aurions eu des problèmes
d'approvisionnement bien plus pointu en
tout cas dans certains pays dans
certaines régions donc mais par contre
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord qu'il y
a un besoin de revoir certains points
bien précis et c'est un travail qui est
lancé par par la commission donc nous
présenterons déjà ça de fin de cette
année une consultation publique et alors
une révision rapide prévue pour le début
2023 une révision ciblée notamment sur
plusieurs objectifs notamment ce qui
est-ce qu'il y a d'être dit comment
faire en sorte que les consommateurs et
le bénéfice du fait que le renouvelable
augmente sa contribution à
l'approvisionnement des cités mais aussi
c'est studios d'investissement qui sont
en effet en effet très important la
transparence du marché l'intégrité du
marché de son des ce sont des justement
des paramètres de notre de notre
révision du système qui est prévu pour
position de la Commission sur une
dissociation du prix de l'électricité à
partir du de la dernière centrale à gaz
est-ce qu'on peut vous avez une position
là-dessus ou on sait quelle est la
position de la France on sait quelle est
la position de l'Allemagne mais est-ce
qu'il y a une position de la Commission
européenne
nous creusons dans le contexte de cette
musique et c'est pour ça que je peux pas
en parler plus en détail mais c'est dans
ce contexte cette révision des sujet
par exemple la le système
ils ont ibérique a été validée a été
validé à l'attribution pour le contexte
espagnol portugais donc c'est il est
passé par une validation à la commission
mais dans le contexte à la vision de du
marché de la cité il y a il y a surtout
pas à mettre de dire comment est-ce que
nous garantit garantissons un équilibre
du marché tout en faisant tout en ayant
une vraie protection des consommateurs
et une transparence donc c'est wait and
Seeb attendent la fin de l'année pour
voir cette question
beaucoup de travail d'accord alors
écoutez vous voulez dire un mot
Christine goupemio je crois qu'il faut
distinguer le court terme et le moyen
long terme comme ça a été dit sur le
court terme
le marché le cadre de marché européen
nous a rendu des grands services dans
les années passées et reste nécessaire
parce que si on veut avec des
interconnexions s'échanger de
l'électricité des carbonées et bien il
faut bien qu'il y a un prix qui soit
fixé et dont tout le monde convient que
c'est le prix alors c'est le prix alors
de la dernière centrale marginale
appelée pour le court terme pour
équilibrer l'offre et la demande au
niveau du système électrique européen
mais là où il y a un sujet plus
structurel c'est pourquoi ce prix de
court terme d'ajustement presque
journalier au niveau européen serait
celui qui déterminerait le prix auquel
dans la durée on achète et on se
projette avec et quand on est un
industriel au-delà des ménages bien sûr
et de la volatilité sur le pouvoir
d'achat il y a la question de
l'industrie comment on peut investir si
on ne sait pas quel sera le prix dans
dans un mois dans un an ou dans deux ans
et c'est ce qui manque en fait c'est une
visibilité du prix de
l'électricité à sur des contrats plus ou
plus longs ça c'est vraiment absolument
important
c'est la première marque que je voulais
faire la deuxième remarque que je vais
faire c'est que dans cette crise je
pense qu'il faut aussi imaginer que
l'inflation qui auquel les pays
européens font face aujourd'hui elle est
liée en partie pour l'énergie qu'on
produit et les problématiques dont nous
débattons là mais il y a un autre sujet
qui se cache derrière ça c'est le prix
des intrants industriels de nos
industries ou finalement c'est le prix
de c'est pas des prix des électrons mais
c'est le prix de l'énergie que nous ne
produisons pas dans notre sol européen
mais qui lui aussi subit un
rangehérissement qui est aussi en train
de pénaliser notre industrie européenne
et française dans la compétition
internationale voilà donc derrière
l'inflation tirée par les prix et nous
avons à remettre cette question à
trouver des solutions européennes il y a
aussi la question de d'une inflexion qui
est tirée quelque part l'énergie que
nous ne produisons pas par les intrants
industriels de nos biens industriels de
notre industrie européenne merci alors
vous avez entendu ce qui vient d'être
dit sa pénalise notre industrialisation
qu'elle a vraiment besoin mais quand
même il faut aussi regarder la situation
française
il y a quand même eu une imprévoyance de
la France en ce qui concerne ses besoins
d'énergie notamment d'électricité
pourquoi certains prévoyance parce que
elle existe non je suis pas sûr que ton
fils dire ça je ce qui est vrai c'est
que aujourd'hui
la France mais l'Europe aussi puisque on
parle quand même de l'Europe c'est même
apparemment le titre de l'émission
ne peuvent pas
se passer d'une réflexion
stratégique sur l'avenir il va falloir
investir il va falloir investir dans de
nouvelles capacités de production et de
distribution et des interconnexions et
investir c'est les industries les
entreprises qui le font c'est les
industries et elle ne peuvent le faire
que si elles ont de la visibilité et
donc il va falloir et au niveau beaucoup
plus européen que français contrairement
à ce que vous dites qu'on accepte que
pour rendre possible les investissements
il faut raisonner pas seulement en
termes de marché il faut raisonner en
termes de capacité à avoir des contrats
long terme en termes de capacité à
stabiliser les prix et en termes de
capacité à réfléchir de manière à un
plan stratégique d'échelonnement des
investissements l'Europe a beaucoup a
été très utile pour mettre en place un
marché commun c'est très bien mais quand
on parle de masse d'investissement à
faire les entreprises ont besoin de
savoir où elles vont et donc il faut un
peu de tempérer
cette volonté de faire fonctionner le
marché par une volonté de rendre le
investissement possible oui je ne perce
bois oui alors la décarbonation du mix
électrique européen va s'accompagner
d'un développement massif de centrale
qu'elle soit nucléaire ou renouvelable
comme une caractéristique c'est que la
part des confits est très élevé par
rapport au coût de fonctionnement à
l'inverse des centrales thermiques comme
les centrales à gaz ou les centrales à
charbon pour lesquelles ce sont les
coûts variables les coûts de
fonctionnement qui sont parce que
l'uranium
nucléaire voilà par conséquent ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'à court terme le
marché est extrêmement volatile envoie
des prix très très volatils et les
fonder sur le coup de fonctionnement
donc pour le long terme si on veut
investir on a besoin d'investir il faut
pouvoir financer les coûts fixes et donc
cette seule solution sur le long terme
c'est en effet des contrats à long terme
qui permettent de couvrir les coûts
complets et des centrales et qui envoie
un signal relativement stable au
consommateur notamment au consommateurs
industriel ça pas qu'on maintienne un
marché un marché de gros pour le très
court terme mais je crois qu'il faut
revoir le modèle pour le moyen long
terme ok alors écoutez il y a quand même
des problèmes en France
si on prend la capacité théorique
de production d'électricité plus de 60
GW
la filière nucléaire française est en
mesure de produire ça mais aujourd'hui
elle en produit à peine 40 alors
qu'est-ce qui a flanché voilà Monsieur
arkim
de façon conjoncturelle il y a la
rencontre de deux problèmes très
différents il y a les effets retard à
retardement de la crise du covid qui
font que on fait toujours des des arrêts
sur les centrales pour faire de la
maintenance de l'entretien
je vous dis pas que ça tombe bien ça
tombe mal effectivement et puis il y a
par ailleurs la découverte d'un
phénomène qui était inattendu à
l'occasion d'un contrôle on a trouvé sur
certains circuits des centrales ce qu'on
appelle la corrosion sous contrainte des
microfissures et qu'il faut traiter il y
a rien de
là de dramatique c'est une solution qui
a été validée par l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire les réparations sont en cours
mais comme vous dites ça tombe pas bien
je peux pas vous dire que ça tombe bien
et que vous pouvez rester en leur disant
quand est-ce que la filière nucléaire
française travaillera plein régime mais
la fille travaille à plein régime que ce
soit Orano ou EDF elle travaille à plein
régime
au travail pour mettre le plus de
tranches possible sur le réseau mais je
pense qu'il faut ça c'est le l'aspect
court terme et évidemment qui est très
important puisque c'est le passage de
cet hiver si on regarde à long terme
comme ça a été dit juste avant il va
falloir investir il va falloir investir
dans des capacités de production
d'électricité des carbonée c'est quoi
c'est ce sont c'est le vent et le soleil
l'éolien et le solaire c'est
l'hydraulique qu'il ne faut pas oublier
qui est très utile parce que on peut
stocker et puis c'est du nucléaire et
c'est important qu'à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne on accepte la
totalité de ces technologies qui on
n'est pas une qui soit privilégiée par
rapport à d'autres parce que sinon le
marché d'ailleurs se retrouve biaisé et
à cette condition si on a des signaux de
long terme si les investisseurs ont un
signal de prix de long terme et que les
clients eux-mêmes qui vont acheter ces
électricité cette électricité voit à
long terme et que toutes les
technologies bas carbone peuvent
contribuer à ce moment-là on pourra
sortir des fossiles importés qui eux
créent vraiment la crise aujourd'hui
c'est pas tellement les difficultés
conjoncturelles du parc français ce sont
c'est le prix des du gaz que nous
importons et là nous avons substitué du
gaz et c'est normal il fallait le faire
on a substitué du gaz américain au gaz
russe ou d'autres pays mais il faut à
terme et la commission il travaille
d'ailleurs faire plus d'énergie
renouvelables il faut aussi faire plus
de nucléaires il y a beaucoup des
amandes qui souhaitent le faire
je voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus
vous avez entendu que
disons les problèmes du marché de
l'électricité
pénalise la réindustrialisation ou
l'industrialisation de la France est-ce
que c'est vrai cette idée qui est qu'on
entend à Paris à savoir que Bruxelles
préfère financer des renouvelables que
le nucléaire
au début de la mission le mixte
énergétique appartient appartient à
chaque État membre donc la Commission ne
prend pas position pour une forme une
forme
d'énergie ce qui se passe ce qui se
passe évidemment c'est qu'il y a une
augmentation et d'ailleurs les chiffres
sont impressionnants pour 2022 et
probablement le seront aussi pour 2023
en termes d'extension du renouvelable
notamment du solaire et donc
l'année 202 sera une année record pour
l'extension du renouvelable en Europe ce
qui d'ailleurs contribue pour remplacer
le gasoil aussi on ne remplace pas
uniquement avec du gaz américain ou du
gaz d'autres et d'autres sources alors
il y a une vraie
reste librement d'aller vers le
renouvelable et moi j'ajouterai aussi
d'autres dimensions quand même à votre
discussion il y a il y a en effet le
besoin d'investissement le besoin de de
stabilité et d'augmenter la capacité de
production on est d'accord mais il y a
aussi un volet de monde et de maîtriser
la demande et là je parle pas d'une
destruction de la demande certainement
pas l'objectif mais il y a il y a des
mesures d'efficacité énergétique et ce
qui nous a permis d'ailleurs cette
traduction de demande à entrer dans dans
cet hiver avec les stocks bien remplis
on a été chercher le gaz autre part mais
on a aussi réduit notre consommation de
gaz
[Musique]
on a beaucoup parlé si vous de la guerre
en Ukraine et notamment des problèmes
de l'électricité du gaz mais tous les
problèmes ne viennent pas de la Russie
avant la ferraire l'Allemagne a proposé
d'injecter 200 milliards d'euros dans
son économie pour soutenir notamment la
transition énergétique pourquoi cela
a-t-il été mal vu en France et critiquée
en France
c'était un cavalier seul comme aurait
dit Richelieu c'est un cavalier seul si
on veut parce que comme on l'a dit les
pays sont interconnectés donc que le
secteur énergétique allemand fonctionne
mieux ça n'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les autres ce qui aurait peut-être
été une meilleure nouvelle pour les
autres c'est s'il n'avait pas arrêté
leur centrale nucléaire parce que là on
serait pas dans la pénurie où on est
aujourd'hui mais c'est plutôt ces
décisions anciennes qui sont à mon avis
contestables que les décisions récentes
qui sont une réponse à une situation de
crise dans lequel ma fois si on avait
200 milliards à dépenser on ferait
pareil
une réponse de circonstances qu'on ne
peut pas le reprocher donc on peut pas
le reprocher mais alors est-ce qu'on
peut reprocher monsieur shelkens à la
Pologne d'avoir choisi la technologie
nucléaire de Westinghouse pour
construire sa première centrale
nucléaire et alors que ce pays reçoit
une aide financière massive de l'Union
européenne pour financer notamment sa
transition énergétique monsieur
shelkensité de ses décisions nous ne
sommes pas dans un dans une européenne
n'est pas une coopération nous forçons
le gouvernements à prendre à choisir des
technologies ou conclure certains
contrats donc ça franchement là pour le
moment la Commission européenne
reste hors de ce débat nous ce que la
stratégie surtout et avant tout cette
défaire d'une
tendance envers la Russie et
ça c'est ce qui reste l'objet principal
derrière ma question il y a une sous
question si vous voulez
vous avez cru comprendre alors je vais
essayer de l'expliciter certains disent
que la Pologne est allée vers l'achat de
cette technologie américaine parce qu'il
y avait pas de financement européen pour
construire une centrale nucléaire en
Pologne est-ce que c'est exact est-ce
que ça aurait pu se faire parce que les
problèmes la France n'a pas on le sait
la France est une grande a une belle
filière nucléaire mais sa trésorerie
peut-être n'autorise pas aujourd'hui de
financement de nouvelles centrales à
l'extérieur est-ce que l'Europe suppléer
à cette chose là
en principe le budget européen les
instruments financiers que nous avons ne
finance pas la construction de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires les ressources
financières dans ce domaine de l'Union
européenne se concentre surtout sur la
sécurité nucléaire et alors aussi ces
dernières années depuis en fait du 15
ans
les mesures pour je crois que le terme
français à la date comme
la démantèlement merci la démantèlement
de certaines centrales de type encore
soviétique qui avait en Bulgarie en
Lituanie et je crois aussi
donc voilà voilà votre réponse j'aperce
moi ça vous satisfait ce que vous
entendez que l'Europe ne peut pas
contrer
qu'un pays européen se dirige dans ses
achats majeurs puisque une centrale
nucléaire ça n'est pas
un magasin d'alimentation vers les
États-Unis plutôt que vers l'Europe et à
votre avis est-ce que il y a moyen de
faire autrement chaque pays est
souverain dans ce domaine la politique
énergétique est en Nationale la Pologne
a le droit de choisir Westland house au
lieu de choisir la centrale française
simplement on voit bien que sur le
nucléaire il y a une bataille au sein
des pays européens qui était très fortes
on peut citer la taxonomie la taxonomie
en effet c'est une liste en quelque
sorte de d'investissement qui peuvent
être aidés indirectement ou directement
par la Commission européenne par des
Finances européens et c'est vrai que là
il y a une bataille franco-allemande
importante les Allemands refusant qu'on
y mette le nucléaire et l'acceptant une
fine et à condition qu'on y met aussi le
gaz ce qui pour une liste de produits
décarbonés et pas je dirais la meilleure
solution alors maintenant chaque pays
est en souverain la Pologne a le droit
pour d'autres raisons je crois qu'il y a
des raisons politiques qui jouent un
rôle important et notamment des raisons
militaires qui sont des raisons liées
évidemment au choix de la centrale
américaine
la première c'est d'abord il y a une
offre française qui est toujours sur la
table il est pas dit que à la fin les
Polonais ne choisissent pas aussi une
autre technologie donc ça c'est c'est
important de le redire et puis je pense
que la question vous avez posé juste une
précision dans l'offre française est-ce
qu'il y a aussi
un projet de financement alors il y a
toujours quand il y a une proposition de
vente de centrale il y a un dialogue
avec le client pour savoir comment ils
veulent financer généralement il y a une
part de capital qui peut être apportée
par le client par l'investisseur et puis
une part de dette qui peut être aussi du
par exemple du crédit sport donc dans le
cas de l'offre faite pour la Pologne oui
bien sûr il y a aussi un volet
financement et je pense que la question
vous avez posé à ce sujet est très
importante parce que on voit par exemple
aujourd'hui les États-Unis proposer de
financer les études de faisabilité de
réacteurs en Europe avec de l'argent
américain évidemment pour de la
technologie américaine et c'est vrai que
ça pose question à l'inverse il y a
encore un débat mais peut-être qu'il
sera tranché dans le bon sens pour
savoir si on peut utiliser les fonds de
relance par exemple le fond les fonds de
oui paroles un des fonds européens non
seulement pour faire des énergies
renouvelables non seulement pour faire
de l'efficacité énergétique et c'est
deux choses sont indispensables mais
aussi pour pouvoir faire du nucléaire
nous pensons que c'est nécessaire est-ce
que vous êtes aussi présent sur un appel
d'offres en République tchèque
absolument il y a c'est un alors c'est
un système et un réacteur qui est
différent mais absolument EDF se
positionne aussi pour présenter un
réacteur en République tchèque et je
crois que ce qui est intéressant dans
ces deux seuls exemples mais on pourrait
en citer beaucoup d'autres c'est qu'il y
a en ce moment beaucoup d'État membres
qui soient veulent faire du nucléaire
alors qu'il n'en faisait pas c'est que
la Pologne c'est quand même majeur mais
aussi d'autres États membres qui disent
que pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2050 pour assurer la sécurité
énergétique à long terme ils veulent
combiner
les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes et du nucléaire et il
faut entendre ça et il faut
objectivement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
une égalité de traitement totale entre
toutes les énergies des carbonées donc
il faut faire mon propos n'est pas dire
qu'il faut privilégier l'un ou l'autre
mais bien les traiter c'est un vieux
débat qu'il faut arrêter c'est pas
nucléaire contre renouvelable c'est on a
besoin des deux pour faire plus
d'électricité des carbonées pour
décarboner l'économie les transports le
bâtiment les chauffages etc tout en
réduisant et la commission l'a dit et
elle a raison il faut aussi réduire bien
sûr la demande l'intervenir
un tout petit peu de recul sur cette
crise que nous vivons effectivement nous
rappelle que l'énergie une valeur que
cette énergie quelle qu'elle soit mais
encore plus les énergies fossiles
puisqu'on a l'ambition de sortie fossile
nous devons l'économiser donc la
question de la demande des économies
d'énergie en électricité comme engage
comme un pétrole devient un sujet clé
un peu comme dans les années 70 après le
premier choc pétrolier finalement en
rappelons-nous l'histoire et cette crise
est peut-être pas la dernière parce
qu'en fait la volatilité des sources
importées nous la subissons alors nous
subissons effectivement la volatilité du
prix du gaz et sa date d'avant la guerre
en Ukraine puisque ça avait commencé fin
2022 avec la reprise de la croissance en
Chine donc le marché mondial du gaz est
au marché extrêmement concurrentiel et
on va le voir aussi au niveau du LNG
aujourd'hui donc il y a une concurrence
donc la volatilité des énergies
importées elle est intrinsèque d'où la
nécessité d'investir sur notre
territoire national sur notre territoire
européen dans une approche
pragmatique c'est à dire technologie
neutral tout ce qui est décarboné ça va
dans le bon sens le nucléaire les EnR et
effectivement même si les pays
choisissent leur mix
ça reste quand même l'affaire de
l'Europe c'est à dire que le nucléaire
ce n'est pas que l'affaire de la France
même si la France fait le choix de
relancer un programme nucléaire c'est
l'affaire de l'Europe parce que l'Europe
dans ces complémentarités du système
électrique interconnecté doit pouvoir
exporter importer dans les moments de
tension d'ailleurs nous la France nous
avons exporté du nucléaire dans toute
l'Europe pendant des années bon
aujourd'hui nous importons en situation
de tension peut-être effectivement de
l'énergie produite à partir de charbon
dans la période de conjoncturel que nous
vivons mais effectivement nous devons
considérer que la meilleure garantie
contre la crise c'est d'investir des
capacités sur notre territoire pour
sortir d'une dépendance
il y a une question un peu idéologique
qui se pose
on parle du nucléaire
on parle des énergies renouvelables mais
les énergies fossiles sont là et utiles
encore un certain nombre d'années le
charbon revient dans de nombreux pays
est-ce que les pays de
qui ont profité en quelque sorte de la
crise énergétique européenne pour
augmenter considérablement le prix du
baril de pétrole est-ce que ça vous
paraît
logique avec une politique de
coopération internationale ou est-ce que
vous y voyez plutôt
l'égoïsme des nations et une espèce de
stratégie
antioxydante à ce niveau à ce qu'on a vu
que l'Afrique d'une certaine manière
c'est rapprochée de la Russie la Russie
la Chine enfin toutes ces puissances si
vous voulez émergente et non
démocratique est-ce que les pays de
l'OPE n'ont pas profité de cette
conjoncture pour avancer leur pion et à
leur tour
s'engager quelque part
qui est des rivalités géopolitiques et
que les blocs civilisationnels se
regardent ne s'aiment pas
rivalise entre eux essayent de se
dominer les uns les autres ça a toujours
été comme ça c'est normal il s'agit pas
de leur reprocher ce qu'il s'agirait
peut-être de faire c'est que en
Occident ou plutôt en Europe parce que
l'Amérique a quand même une
problématique très différente de
l'Europe nous passions la même chose
nous avons des intérêts qui se trouvent
d'ailleurs être les intérêts de la
planète sur un point important c'est que
nous avons besoin d'avoir moins
d'énergie fossiles pour des raisons
géopolitiques mais c'est également bon
pour la planète que nous ayons moins
d'énergie fossiles donc les Européens
arrêtent de se disputer entre eux sur la
nature des énergies des carbonées à
construire qu'il permet et qu'il se
mette à en construire tout et
effectivement je n'aime pas les
centrales à charbon non j'ai des
énergies décarbonées
des énergies étaient carbonées
l'objectif est là le mérite de l'Europe
c'est
on répondait pas à ma question est-ce
que ces pays de l'OPEP en augmentant le
coût du baril non ne sont pas allés vers
une une démarche antioxydant le pont du
baril il voulait avoir plus d'argent ce
qui est ce que n'importe qui ferait à
leur place que derrière il y a bien sûr
que derrière
la crise sauf que sauf que je suis même
pas si sûr parce que regardez les pays
de l'OPE ce n'est pas une c'est n'est
pas une unité le plus gros producteur de
pétrole l'Arabie Saoudite est un allié
de l'Occident
du point de vue géopolitique d'autres
effectivement ne nous aiment pas
beaucoup mais donc le seul point commun
qu'ils ont c'est qu'ils veulent
maximiser leur fait gagner le maximiser
leurs revenus et nous notre intérêt
c'est de faire en sorte que nous n'ayons
pas besoin d'eux ou le moins ou le moins
possible et pour ça il faut que les
Européens arrêtent de se disputer
étaient construisent du décarbonate
construisent du renouvelable et
construisent du nucléaire sans en faire
un sujet
pour le coup idéologique parce que c'est
l'idéologie antinucléaire en Europe me
paraît beaucoup plus gênante que
l'idéologie antioxydantale qui forcément
existe dans la partie du monde qui n'est
pas l'Occident a commencé par la Russie
alors Monsieur arkima y a rien paradoxe
d'un côté les pays de l'OPEP augmentent
le coût du baril de pétrole et vous vous
ne pouvez pas augmenter le prix de
l'électricité et même vous le vendez à
un prix sous-évalué une entreprise comme
ça ne peut pas
garantir sa solvabilité financière
pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure la clé
pour une entreprise qui investit dans
des capacités de production qui vont
durer 40 ans 60 ans voire plus c'est de
pouvoir couvrir le coup de cet
investissement sur cette durée et donc
ça ça veut dire effectivement plus de
contrats à long terme avec les clients
ou avec les états
ça veut dire aussi que on doit réduire
le coût des financements parce que ce
sont des investissements qui requiert
beaucoup de capitaux c'est vrai
notamment pour les centrales
hydrauliques les centrales nucléaires et
donc il y a des modèles qui permettent
de réduire le coût du financement et
donc infininer le coût pour le
consommateur donc ça on a besoin de ces
de ces deux choses et puis on a besoin
d'avoir un peu de visibilité quand même
sur le mix à long terme et c'est vrai
que c'est de la responsabilité des États
membres mais c'est vrai aussi qu'il y a
une dimension européenne parce que on
peut pas par exemple se reposer
entièrement sur les interconnexions pour
dire ah mais si j'ai pas assez de
capacité un jour je verrai importer de
mon voisin de d'à côté à gauche ou à
droite et donc il y a un moment besoin
au niveau européen que les États la
Commission les gestionnaires de réseau
regardent les planifications
énergétiques qui existent pour dire on a
assez de capacité
que je vous pose c'est pourquoi EDF a
accepté le principe de la reine qui est
un prix sous est-ce qu'il fallait pas le
refuser d'emblée
vous posez je vous pose une question qui
en fait s'adresse plus aux régulateur à
l'État
prend la réglementation qu'on lui
propose mais mais non mais votre
question est fragilisé l'entreprise en
fait votre question elle met le doigt
sur le point clé qui est avoir des prix
qui couvrent les coûts des
investissements et effectivement pendant
longtemps y compris parce que l'énergie
était pas chère et que ça satisfaisait
beaucoup
de gens en Europe et ailleurs on a
imaginé que il était on pouvait vivre
avec des prix durablement très bas et en
réalité il y a eu un sous-investissement
et aujourd'hui on en paye le prix on a
fait des erreurs collectivement dans le
passé
j'aperçois la reine c'était une bêtise
la reine sur le principe s'explique par
le contexte dans lequel le mécanisme a
été mis en place c'est une loi qui a
fixé la reine je dirais
ça consiste pour permettre aux
concurrents des DF de gagner des parts
de marché comme il n'avait pas
l'avantage du nucléaire qui était
largement amorti ça obligeait des f
avant une partie de sa production à
l'époque c'était 25% puisque EDF
produisait plus de 400
limitée à 100 terawater donc EDF avait
l'obligation de par la loi c'est pas un
choix des DF avec l'obligation de par la
loi de vendre une partie de son
nucléaire a pris coup de temps
simplement ce qui était prévu c'est que
ce fameux prix qui au départ était fixé
à 42 euros mégawattheure au 1er janvier
2012 devait évoluer dans le temps tenir
compte en tenant compte de l'inflation
en tenant compte des coûts nouveaux que
le nucléaire allait supporter bon le
système a pas été respecté donc il y a
eu un effet pervers alors c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui le nucléaire historique je
dirais récupère à peu près ses formes
mais EDF son nucléaire historique a un
prix qui est très très en dessous du
prix de gros du prix du marché c'est là
où il y a un manque à gagner pour EDF
ceci étant ce système permet quand même
il faut le souligner aux consommateurs
particulières et même aux consommateurs
industriels de bénéficier d'un prix
relativement stable aujourd'hui si le
consommateur français domestique a eu
une augmentation de 4% seulement 2022
c'est grâce à ça mécanisme de la reine
bien évidemment vous voulez dire quelque
chose là-dessus Christine Gouvet bio en
fait que la reine résulte de la loi
noble de 2010 c'est une loi c'est pas
c'est pas les acteurs économiques qui
qui ont décidé et la philosophie de
départ c'était de dire les consommateurs
ont le droit de changer de fournisseur
c'est l'ouverture des marchés et donc
quel que soit leur fournisseurs ils
doivent bénéficier de l'investissement
historique de la France dans le
nucléaire donc c'est juste une petite
nuance que j'apporte sur le fait que
c'est les consommateurs français qui ont
le droit quel que soit leur fournisseur
de bénéficier du nucléaire existant pour
autant la question qui dispose
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir comment on
va financer le les nouveaux programmes
c'est à dire le futur puisque finalement
les centrales nucléaires existantes même
en les prolongeant on pourra les
prolonger 10 15 ans mais au-delà de ça
nous devons préparer l'avenir de la
France en termes de mixe électrique des
carbonée pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants donc 2045 2050 c'est
demain à l'échelle du temps industriel
merci la reine ne prévoyait pas le
financement du nouveau nucléaire c'est
très clair législateur a bien dit comme
tous les consommateurs ont participé au
financement du nucléaire historique qui
sont légitimes qu'ils soient EDF ou pas
de profiter du mécanisme ceci étant le
nouveau nucléaire ce sont de nouvelles
questions brièvement mais très
brièvement effectivement la reine telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est un poison
pour une entreprise
bien sûr mais c'est ça c'est l'affaire
du du législateur non mais bien sûr oui
c'est un poison comme vous êtes une
entreprise et vous ne pouvez pas vendre
le produit que vous produisez au bon
tarif et que voilà lentement vous perdez
de l'argent effectivement ça n'est pas
une bonne chose ça si c'est si c'était
ça la réponse qu'il y a à voir elle est
très claire
[Musique]
alors vous voyez la citation de Bruno
Latour qui est un éminent écologiste qui
dit l'Europe est seule oui mais seul
l'Europe nous sauver alors nous allons
conclure si vous voulez avec le peu de
temps qui nous reste sur cette question
monsieur shelkens parmi les solutions
envisagées actuellement lesquels vous
paraissent à privilégier au niveau de la
Commission européenne la fin de
l'indexation du prix de l'électricité
sur le prix du gaz l'augmentation des
capacités de stockage du gaz et de
l'électricité en développant la filière
hydrogène l'augmentation de la
production des énergies renouvelables et
du nucléaire un acheteur européen unique
et la création d'un grand marché
européen
refonder de fond en comble le marché
d'électricité et pour ajouter une cerise
sur le gâteau est-ce qu'il faut pas de
réparé à fond européen mutualisé pour
l'énergie vous voyez et pour tout ça
vous avez deux minutes pas plus à vous
monsieur shelkens
je vous remercie pour une
on a entendu votre rire
d'adhésion ou critique mais en tout cas
vous avez la parole on a malheureusement
peut-être mais en fait quels sont les
priorités pour vous grosso modo voilà si
vous étiez à la manette et avec un coup
de baguette sur quoi vous actionne votre
action porterait immédiatement
les deux les deux objectifs principaux
restent même l'indépendance par rapport
aux attentations Russes et la transition
de la transition
énergétique vers leur
qualité climatique pour 2050 donc pour
reprendre vos questions ce que vous avez
nous travaillons déjà ce plaisir de ces
questions qu'on a déjà parlé de
nous travaillons en effet sur une
plateforme d'agrégation de la demande et
la possibilité la possibilité d'achat
conjoint donc ça c'est déjà en route la
négociation la négociation sur cette
législation au moins possible il ne faut
pas encore formellement approuver mais
on en principe donc ça c'est c'est en
route le travail sur le stockage du gaz
a été une priorité pendant pendant cette
année le sera aussi l'année prochaine et
notamment du côté investissement
l'hydrogène ou je dois dire les signaux
font très encourageants et avec de
nombreux projets donc tout ça ce sont
ces en effet les priorités et alors pour
revenir pour revenir au nucléaire cela
reste un choix national dans toutes dans
toutes nos modèles qui mène à la
neutralité
climatiques éco 2050 il y a évidemment
une augmentation très forte
la fille une politique industrielle
européenne c'est absolument clé pour
qu'on tire le meilleur de cette
transition énergétique merci madame
monsieur qui Maya la priorité c'est
d'avoir plus d'électricité décarbonée et
moins d'énergie fossile pas seulement du
fossile importé de Russie moins de
fossiles en général aujourd'hui la part
de l'électricité en mixte stagne voire
d'essence qui est très inquiétant donc
oui moi je suis d'accord on a beaucoup
d'atouts notamment industriel en Europe
et l'action on doit le mettre sur la
réduction de la demande l'efficacité
énergétique et la réduction de la
demande et la production d'électricité
décarbonée sinon on atteindra ni la
sécurité énergétique ni la décarbonation
nos économies je suis une question très
brève et qui vous concerne directement
est-ce que vous avez confiance est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est faisable que
le EDF remplissent son programme
nucléaire tel qu'il a été proposé par le
Président de la République oui on fait
tout pour
tout pour alors sur la question
européenne Jacques Perse bois vous
rajoutez quoi comme priorité moi je
pense que la priorité c'est de faire
baisser le prix de l'électricité en
subventionnant le gaz utilisé pour la
production d'électricité quitte à
prélever des surprofis pour le faire et
à moyen terme il faut réfléchir à un
nouveau design et le nouveau design et
bien c'est un système d'acheteur unique
avec des contrats à long terme
permettant de couvrir les coûts fixes et
coût variables des centrales par des
systèmes d'appel d'offres tout en
laissant un marché pour le très court
terme et les échanges aux frontières
alors Armand la Ferrer qu'est-ce que
vous rajoutez et que il faut il faut
construire il faut construire il faut
préparer l'avenir on va voir l'avenir
sans à construire de nouvelles capacités
alors dans toute l'Europe dans toutes
les technologies des carbonées la France
a déjà lancé le mouvement pour
construire des réacteurs nucléaires
c'est très bien ça ne suffira pas vous
êtes prêts Orano à dans le mécano à
assurer on est on est prêt à assurer bon
il y a un petit détail qui est pour
l'instant on a décidé comment on allait
faire pour les réacteurs mais il y a
tout un site autour qui est ce dont ma
société s'occupe pour lequel il va
falloir également prendre des décisions
mais mais il y a pas que la France il y
a pas que le nucléaire il y a du
nucléaire hors de France il y a d'autres
technologies il faut maintenant que les
Européens construisent l'avenir de leur
propre production et énergétique voilà
ma goûté il me reste à vous merci mais
je vais avant de nous quitter et je
voudrais vous présenter une brève
bibliographie alors un pavé si on ose
dire Jacques Perse bois vous avez écrit
ce livre économie et politique avec
Jean-Pierre Hansen et Alain Janssens
énergie bon il y a tout là-dedans c'est
la Bible
c'est une synthèse de différents types
d'énergie absolument c'est une synthèse
des différents types d'énergie je
voudrais signaler également
cet ouvrage de Bernard à Goyer une
affaire d'état la tentative de sabordage
du nucléaire français c'est un pro de
mots c'est vraiment
le souhait que la filière nucléaire soit
la plus brillante possible est-ce que
vous avez publié récemment une étude à
l'Union française d'électricité
Christine l'électricité avec tous ces
adhérents suit le rythme de consultation
et de proposition des différents
Conseils européens pour être
utile sur cette réflexion autour d'un
cadre de marché qui nous permette de
réussir cette transition énergétique
merci Monsieur shelken c'est ce que vous
avez un ouvrage à proposer au niveau de
la Commission européenne ou peut-être de
des choses vous même je n'ai rien publié
du tout mais je suis je serais très
intéressé de dire les ouvrages qui
ouvrages qui viennent d'être cités merci
monsieur arkimaïa je recommande la
lecture des scénarios énergétiques de
RTE qui sont très bien faits et qui
démontrent qui mettent à plat les
hypothèses économiques et techniques
pour prévoir le mix de demain de façon
très sérieuse et des passionnée et c'est
j'en recommande vivement la lecture au
moins du résumé
d'ailleurs je pense merci de vos
précisions merci Madame merci Monsieur
d'avoir participé à cette émission fort
instructive sur une question d'actualité
merci à l'équipe
delcp d'avoir permis la réalisation de
cette émission à la fois à Paris et à
Bruxelles et avant de nous quitter je
vous suggère cette réflexion de
l'Institut BRUGEL
la crise de l'énergie représente le plus
grand risque systémique pour l'Europe
[Musique]